ich gehe und wo ich stehe da sitzt der
im dach und nacht
es ist dort mein leben als mutter
sowieso nicht los naja
mit 1 0 so raus es gab heute noch dich
begreifen warum ausgerichtet
die delegation hier war die haben uns ja
auch nichts erzählt
das plus mit arbeitskollegen wollte
nochmal so horch und herr die haben ein
bisschen mit deutlichen worten ich nicht
was vollständig und als meine fragen
offen
sie hatte sich das immer dann wenn man
gefragt damit ihr wart doch dabei war
doch auch auf ihr müsstet doch was
gesehen habe
du heilige sagt schimmel bleibt er hat
enorm lange haare und helle haare und
den snowboard hier in der bagno
snowboard
der tunnelbau da unten das koffein
richtig große sache des kosmos das war
schon mal hat mir mal gesagt es war
schwerer arbeit da unten im tunnel
es war nichts leichtes amt das geld was
wir verdient hast dass du auch verdient
dass eine geschenkt gekriegt er doch
immer gesagt es war eine schwere arbeit
ja das will ja keiner absprechen aber es
war ihm der 22
der tunnelbau schlechthin und das war
das war schon stolz
er hat gesagt dass es gefährliche arbeit
ist ja und das amt der erste tödliche
unglück war von gera war das wohl der
lemgoer hat eine eisenstange von oben
auf den kopf stellen
das hat uns mal erzählen da habe ich nur
sagen hoffentlich passiert nicht
eingetreten
eigentlich viel zusammen gemacht dass
kommunalen schlag ist es vorbei zu
vergessen wird er nie
auf keinen fall das ist sowieso nicht
weil ich lasse meine art und weise nur
den tod mit der sie den grabstein gesagt
geboren drauf und todestag